do you think he could be a good
president someday in like eight years 16
years I mean you endorsed him once he's
got some Talent you're kind of crushing
him right now someday could he be
president well I endorsed him once and
he was losing badly and because of the
endorsement he wanted a landslide the
following literally the following day
look right now I'm very down on him I'm
a Believer in loyalty and I'm a Believer
in other things and he has obviously not
run a very good campaign because he's
getting he's getting crushed Now
understand that there is no campaign yet
that's the most interesting thing about
this Trump is acting as though DeSantis
is running a campaign now you could
argue well he sort of is but he hasn't
announced because he's feeling it out
okay it's not actually a campaign and
there's a question as to if and how the
Dynamics will change